bene a tutti ragazzi perché questo video
parigi oggi siamo tornati per ragazzi e
grazie signore e tutti maschi così mi
sento in forma il ragazzo che schifo ma
in piedi buttiamo ancora adesso
prima di tutto ci hanno i piedi stavolta
c'è questo periodo vi lasciamo al video
che l'ha tolto abbiamo lasciato in
sospeso ma insomma 8 il clip però dai
primi dati che le 100 svegli tasso si
mobilita la catena di lanciarlo
sull'imposta ragazzi ci riesce
no la band ha tentato la pratica 600
attenzione basta basta finisce brava a
[Musica]
battere con la dizione concentrati per
mila merli e non il marco botto
sviluppata c'è poi la serie a ha vinto
il termine
va beh insomma è che tutta quella cara
regione insegnati per poi un'ora grazie
quella che quest'anno dimetterà solare
nome la storia
grande è stato fantastico
potrebbe essere una forza non faremo
questo tipo league of legends a devo
entrare nel buco
tu sei bravissimo dai ciò fa appendendo
zio prima ten è vero sembravo simon
treni booking complimento papa lo del
vino diventa appunto ma questo qui se
non c'è paura di lei sono io non vi team
honda via basta
poi dicono che chi non fa 1 2 e 3
formativo che arrivano simili ci aiuti
sì sì sì sì mission si fissione va bene
vediamo anche su chi voleva fare tanto
che combina infatti ed aia di culo da
favola gioconda scusa ma tu che stai per
lancia critiche che non si parlavano
questo pensiamo a livello è bravo
a livello richiesto di una volta e basta
bye bye bye e un anno sono capace parlo
dico e faccio parte dai papà come se
tutto tuo papà che devo farvi saltare
poco jump e questo si sa che questo si
va avanti se è proprio questo cazzo di
pompeo devi saltare non morire papa il
quale si leggeva animati che io posso
fare praticamente adesso aspettate se ci
sono calma calma calma ma è bravo papà
fatto ha fatto le olimpiadi anche lui
tudor non mi boicottare ti sembra un
disco battuta un successo progettando lo
sai che ti faccio ma bravo sono vivo
solo perché ci sono i colori st
cambiavano questo è difficile farmi un
ninja che resti ter devo passare in
mezzo tito starò mai facendo così così
mi sa di no si fa la doccia in base ai
dati di tutti i tempi
bravo si è scolato me lo volevano vedere
la vita skill dai circa livello
difficile vero che immaginiamo cosa devi
vincere ma che alla calma attenzione in
questo punto adesso valigie mitrano
musica aveva scritto in color correction
bande nere da film sono perché la cosa
importante è un po di questa ora se
fossi bollare vuol dire che dentro il
possibile che aspetta carta quindi
musica pica cinematica bandini le è
sbarcata per le bande nere livello e
nero pronti
mezz'ora di cose si capiscono i buoni
che ti prego io non ci vado lì al
massimo ma il bastone se poi si staccava
calciatori di stanca ma anche se mi
leggerò dall'altra parte svetta tutta
una gamma di pagare alla gamba chiamare
il cuore la gamma la testa cosa ad
arrivare tutto arrivare tipo questa è
nicki minaj sisto livelli veramente un
simile è proprio impossibile impossible
non arriva vivo maledizione perché come
fai arrivare vip il livello del no devi
fare il decisore un brit vita bene a non
saper fare ma io conosco solo il click
day è arrivato fino in porto come fatto
ad arrivare vivo con il caso di uno
sticker sì ma in questo che ti trova al
lavoro perché siamo a youtube a
raccontare un lavoro veramente anche il
lavoro vero il fatto che famiglie e ai
video ma i video con di somma grazie
papà sei bravissimo di fi il lanciatore
persona capace neanche di fare come
gravissime v3 centrare il buco con la
palla non riesco a fare neanche quello e
questo è il lavoro lanciare le palle e
bechar cose non vengano cerchiamo subito
ma è un bel chiarino papavrami dei soldi
può fare ma ma il canale di questo non
ci guardiamo xxx quadricicli a cercare
di mettere giù e di qua non sei capace
sei un fallito fatti a cercare un lavoro
vero
adesso no non di andare il buco
e solo 10 assist my work labo 2000 e
amore in cui bambini
ecco quello che mi dice vi prego
e l'età di farle scesa a due anni e
taglio dei bonus track
questo era capito cos'è e quello
e quello che dice valigie volo di che
squadra e lo fanno l'incidente
appoggiato ball jump volgia di vista di
questo scacco da ma perché ci cese la
pista che lo star registra chiaro
addosso papa in programma nuove non lo
so ho vinto col cuore l'importante via
metterci cuore nei livelli sbagliata che
non sono capaci a farlo youtuber papa
tutto sconnesso aiuto no basta informi
in.pu.t dovrebbe pagare per per usare
quella pozzi photoshop bubuf niente
affanculo mi sono rotto le balle non
sono capaci senza hezbollah guardato
quello di parti panda capelli stars è
una balla tra fin qui è capito se come
ci sono bombe non esplodono mai avevamo
vedi che non esclude un po di qui non
giovanissimo rinuncerebbero a fare
questo ribadirlo perché sei ubriaco
tagli dai così
[Musica]
profeta così sì perché mi si stesse
scappando per capitan che schifo lo
scatto lamento vinto una bella la
tattica parlo spesso dato i regali spara
e vinci di albertino e lega aspetta
calma 321 piazza la sparando papa solo
che uno fa rompo con poco pane
bluemotion a camminare perché sono
attori con poco bancherelle realizzando
di a fare queste bastare di camminare e
camminare sfascia la spada ma che sarà
in basso per un curvone che risalta la
destra salta tutto e poi è finito e c'è
il canale dei regi lagni 45
eccolo eccolo ciao joan come sentire la
voce di johnny bravo pativa messo alla
mori capito anche emanato è una fiera
del gioco ma se c'era wall che ti hanno
copyright per metà musica la smetta
ragazzo marocchino che cantavi domani si
possa apprezzare solo viste durante la
testa forno mare con la bocca che sembra
quando si inchioda la porta accanto alla
l'iva e facciamo milanesi di casa ha
detto ciò vorrei farvi sentire il
compito questa tipo del culo pratico e
qualche altro che un livello di
nuovissimi mio dio che troll che si sono
illusioni più grandi della mia vita dopo
la mia ex che dissi nato ex infatti
mentre pensavo questa roba mia morto
moglie l'ha fatta ma basta a giano visto
di essere modelle che sei arrivato tu
sei morto
un'emozione non si emoziona rock swing
swing pop singer figura deciso di fare
una cosa che non riesco a fare che
aggrapparsi a noi dovremo l'arti prima
però sicuramente grazie per quanto
riguarda la toccavo ai ragazzi lo stesso
come pare aver tabella chimico meta
bergamasco bravissimo come noi ha ben
chiara lenti l'urlo di papa e mettiamo
[Applauso]
noi giovinco drigo e tanto il mio corpo
cazzo è a van gogh non si pone parlare
di riserve in tanto e ho perso atto meno
tempo di record la parte la sfida e dai
e dai a bari è da ieri da un giorno io
abbia va bene vinto dai ragazzi questa è
la fine del bisogno ho letto i commenti
avete scritto le parole privati dopo gli
occhi neri capelli sempre dentro il
bagno che la fatti con un pastello e
devo prendere un pastello per farsi
porta si parla di quello che sai fare
più rock no vabbè ok lampo e basta
[Musica]